the name's James Bond James Bond
I'd like a margarita we did this on Dino
time sure how about the jetpack you
didn't the madhurima say looking for
your pot of gold same as s omething t
dolt we are out of original ideas
no we're hacks why does everything I do
sound like a leprechaun looper has this
video called the no time to die trailer
explained this is a tough war dear video
requests from mikhail lyndon number kale
if you guys a know this homeboy from
sweden we would always talk about two
things and I would always mention two
things in his shadow he's been a patron
for a long time which is how he's from
Sweden and how he's obsessed with James
Bond and he's asked us to cover videos
in the past hour about bond
he's been heavily anticipating this
trailer so of course once this trailer
came out I was expecting nothing less
than a patron video request of a bond
thing so of course we got the no time to
die trailer McHale seems very happy
about it and if there's anyone with bond
inside especially if he's gonna share a
video like this with us I'm gonna
already be like I trust this video
yeah from kales happy I'm happy exactly
let's do this the end of an era has
arrived no time to die will be Daniel
Craig's Final Four reyes British
superspy James Bond his fifth Bond film
in 14 years making him the longest
serving man to play that role there's
many funny dates the longest time the
Swans drive off into the sunset at the
end of Spectre was apparently the only
retirement announcement mi6 was ever
going to get bond took off to Jamaica
to live an idyllic existence on the
water he's been there with Swan for five
years but his colleagues believing he's
dead from the end of 2015 to the
beginning of 2020s no time to die the
real-life and fictional timelines
basically align here life has gone on
without
and exactly as he wanted it's given the
ships mostly security to replace him as
a double O agent and acquire a
significant amount of experience Nomi
also appears to take on a more
militaristic tactical style become
destined operations compared to bun
suave tuxedo look dr. Swan is hiding
something I blame you Banda Madeleine
will break up following bat betrayal
consider her father was mr. white be
assassinated mr. white
she was very aware respect his existence
she no doubt has an insidious history
she's worked to burry if she knew about
her father's criminal ties was she
possibly more of a party to it than she
originally led on it's also possible dr.
Swan has some connection to Sutphin the
villain played by Rami Malek because
she's been sent the same mask he wears
good bomb D trying to avoid me
experiencing the heartbreak Vesper Lynd
put him through at the end of kostina oh
yeah
[ __ ] at the end of spectrum until
English inspector leader and staffer
Blofeld played by Christoph Waltz to mi6
head Emma for arrest now in custody and
under what appears to be solitary
confinement
Blofeld is a highly important prisoner
it's the most valuable asset this
country has but they're weak good super
villain knows how to turn the screws one
in captivity until the moment they can
once more act independently like one
Ferrari is what Jules is back to
character archetypes like his again and
again Hannibal Lecter became a movie
icon from a prison cell after all Emma
spun to not lose control in Blofeld's
presence given all the horrors Blofeld
is orchestrated and inflicted upon bombs
light bond says he would never do that
but then turns the corner to find dr.
Swann with the folder clearly suggesting
it's like a logical profile they haven't
seen each other in what seems like a
while and now meet here preparing to
speak with both belly Blofeld knows dr.
Swann secret - and weaponizing yet again
spawn - surely a master stroke in a
grand plan it's been a while since
you've seen CIA agent Felix Leiter and
the James Bond franchise the character
has been a staple of Bond franchise
films since the first film dr. no
Jim played by Jeffrey Wright hasn't
appeared since 2008 Quantum of Solace
only rating a mention inspector in no
time to die
lighter seeks out his now retired friend
to take an off-the-books assignments
I'll be coming for Surrey only one I
trust her skin Luther back how does he
know bond isn't dead we need answers
Felix long time James Bond franchise
producer Barbara broccoli describes rami
malek suffering as the one that really
gets end up on skin a nasty piece of
work
first one ended he even holds us gonna
build Lee his villainous connections
unclarified in the trailer what it's
difficult to believe air tomorrow I'll
tie back to Spencer and Bluebell in
summers yet unknown way and some of
funds are theorized he's really an
updated doctor no he was a member of
Spectre the word know is them the total
of the movie after all between himself
and bond even saying he could be
speaking to his own reflection
when monologuing to the famous agent but
he sees one big obvious difference
- it seems like the stakes in their time
to die with involve Bonzo mortality
against the world threatening plots that
have become standard for the franchise
with no time to die Craig is officially
finished playing bond and nobody has
been officially announced to replace him
audiences will be saying goodbye to a
specific iteration of bonds that has
transformed a franchise we've known for
50 years
Craig's bonds are scum from being a
fresh-faced rookie in Casino Royale and
to basically a hermit who actively hates
his job code is humanity he's an orphan
who was never known familial connections
except for with one person Judi Dench's
M who died a terrible death right in
front of him the character James Bond
there's often being completely wrong and
time and again being portrayed as
desperate he's never mortal superhero
he's human and he asked the help because
he knows exactly where his strengths
begin and end as much as their noise him
to emitter and he is always always tired
that doesn't cheap in his bond it makes
it more real and no time to die trailer
sets the stakes around bond himself is
like its friends is love the threatened
destruction isn't strictly political
social it's personal which is really the
perfect bookends first maybe James Bond
does need to die and in doing so
represent the humanity that's been so
central to the character since Casino
Royale fans can find out everything when
no time to die opens in theaters April
2nd 2020 in the UK and April 8th 2020 in
the US check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more link to
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
subscribe to the bail oh dude it loved
the bail so much great content on that
bail they didn't talk about how when
bond is walking down the hallway and
then he turns and shoots the gun you're
not inside the barrel yeah I mean is
that the opening is that the ending mmm
it could be the ending or is just a
scene it's if it's two-thirds of the way
through the movie and it's got no
connective tissue around it maybe they
have an origin to explain where he was
Milwaukee
and what he's heard yeah we finally fill
in the origin tale that's what I want to
know every detail guys come on dude you
know what I've realized through all this
bond coverage that Remy Malik's in it
what yeah who's Ramy Malik oh the guy
from iRobot from Rocket Man now there's
no song yet and there's not been an
artist announced yet oh well they're
green a full circle so they're gonna get
both Adele and Jack why did the last
Chris Cornell that the first one there
so oh yeah that's a great song they
talked a lot about Madeleine Swann in
here potentially being some type of you
know like of course the psychological
element was something we picked up on
but that she has some like deeper darker
secrets I thought that was just bond
being paranoid again
from the way the trailer communicated it
to meet ya the ability to trigger the
memory of Eva Green's character from
Casino Royale sure but then it looks
like they're vacationing or living in
the Paradise life and then they start
getting attacks I thought he was just
like putting blame on her for why they
were caught yeah or like he wasn't able
to truly decompress and let go so he's
like standing there by the water be like
I don't know you know I don't know if I
can actually trust the story's dry we
all have secrets you know yeah it's safe
to say that bond suspects foul play
yeah I'm ready to say that since they
started talking about her in this looper
oh I've been alright I just gotta find a
way to naturally get there and I did I
don't even care about her character I
just wanted to make that little joke I
feel better just being next to you for
that I mean it totally blows my looper
the movie looper joke out of the water
though saying I didn't have won this
thing as I've been trying to be like oh
hey uh looper Rian Johnson but you know
okay no why shoot here if we're really
trying too hard John I know really try I
didn't have an in but then you brought
up Rian Johnson movie gotta do it now
leshawna Lynch's character oh my god she
could be the same one from Captain
Marvel both have military style
background
training and ability if she flies a
plane all bets are off
all bets are off it's definitely tied
she's the same character I like what
they pointed out that little detail
though of how she is more military
tactic style you could see in her
demeanor and everything she's doing in
the trailer the little bits that's
something I did not quite latch on to I
kind of I'd want her to be something
more that's like female bond yeah
morally a little male wiser oh yeah yeah
manizer come off the wood I felt like
that would be fun to see that instead of
because just like racking up to drinking
martinis Cap'n hook why not we haven't
gotten that yet so find them to explore
every creepy Bond trope but from the
female person I want her to pick up a
dude at a Funeral all that yeah there's
been rumors that they're setting her up
to maybe have a spinoff or something I
keep getting the vibe that she's like a
bad guy I wouldn't be surprised if that
happened especially just because I'm
using my own excitement as like a gauge
for that I'm like I'm excited for this
character I'm a little worried about
that because her moments in the trailer
are really cool yeah I've heard some
people say that with the woke climate we
live in that it would be a bad idea to
kill off your new a female black
character to me I was just like she's
probably back then you know all the way
there would be the double O six twist
again maybe the main villain even bigger
than Blofeld I don't like the idea of
rami malek
being doctor doctor now I am NOT a fan
of that idea they tried doing the whole
con thing like with Benedict Cumberbatch
and into darkness they did that with a
bit of a Blofeld thing inspector I
didn't really care for it I actually
weirdly like that they're carrying over
all the immediate events of Spectre to
this despite how Spectre was not
well-received cuz they didn't really
seem to care all that much about Quantum
of Solace when they did hello everybody
was quick to forget one time so yes
they're really making you go I guess I
got a rewatch Spectre so I can
completely understand this movie No
time to die but with bloopers video
really made me do is realize the overall
tragic story art and human side of bonds
character art with the Daniel Craig
franchise so before I was like I guess
I'll go back and watch Spectre but now
it's making me go I guess I'll binge all
the Daniel Craig movies well it doesn't
make it interesting because yeah now we
can assess them as their own era of this
franchise and we can now you know zoom
out and look at how they evolved and how
they complement each other the way we
couldn't necessarily before and I don't
know exactly what to expect in terms of
finality from this movie but I think it
would be nice if they could make it feel
final in some way for this era you know
especially because this was a rebrand
for the series trying out a new tone and
everything and if they're gonna get a
new bond I almost feel like they should
really change the slate again
yeah awkwafina awkwafina yeah totally
they're both James Bond's can - James
Bond's let's get four women to play
James
let's just go to town like that I like
Jeffrey Wright a lot and I know the
Felix characters been in the Bond
franchise for a while so I imagine that
for hardcore Bond fans are really
excited about that and I'd really like
the impression Jeffrey Wright left and
Casino Royale Quantum I barely remember
anything they talked about so I guess
I'm excited I mean all I remember is a
lot of harsh shaky camera I am very
excited for this they've put a lot of
TLC into developing this movie I mean
the amount of like director hired
director fire and Daniel Craig wanting
to make sure that he returns he wants to
make sure that this is a great one that
he can go out on so it seemed like every
choice they made was we're only going to
do this if we know this can be great we
will not pursue because this has been a
while since Spectre and that was a
pretty not ugly ugly but that was a
pretty angsty time you could tell that
there wasn't a lot of good blood on that
project
no and then here it seems like they only
cared to make sure this is a great film
and there's a lot of people like I watch
online who were like honestly the
trailer surprised me
and a lot more than I expected - whoo so
yeah rootin for him I'm excited for this
guy's got any theories about Remy
Malik's character leshawna Lynch's
character leave a comment down below you
can subscribe to the real rejects click
our notification Bella get notified
whenever got a video out hit the like
button or dislike button don't matter
and make sure to subscribe to looper
while you're at it as well thank you
guys very much for being here and Mikael
I hope you're happy